see that shirt is not a good color on
you
there is nothing fans love more than
watching their favorite TV BFFs be
adorable on screen unfortunately what
you see on TV isn't always how things
play out in the real world these actors
may have played writer die best friends
on the small screen but when the camera
stopped rolling they weren't exactly
buddy-buddy with their on-screen pal it
is impressive that they certainly did a
good job of masking their rivalries but
today we'll be looking at some of
televisions most notable frenemies over
the years you are a free chick just for
doing that yeah who pretends to be a
psychopath just as thieves you could
pull it off before ariana grande was the
biggest name in pop music she was a
Nickelodeon star playing high schooler
Cat Valentine
on Victorious meanwhile Victoria Justice
starred as a series lead Tori Vega Tori
and cow were best friends throughout all
four seasons of the show which ended
with Grande's character being sped off
into the series Sam and cat both
actresses claimed the real-life tension
between them was low-key however it's
hard to ignore all the shade throwing
some fans blame Sam and cat for the
cancellation of victorious but Grande
denied all the allegations when asked on
social media why Victoria's ended grande
wrote in 2013 the only reason victorious
ended is because one girl didn't want to
do it while it might be a coincidence
that justice happened to go on her own
solo music tour immediately after the
conclusion of the series just as
seemingly confirmed Grande's post was
about her when she wrote some people
would throw someone that they considered
a friend under the bus just to make
themselves look good
hashtag stop being a phony hashtag if
they only knew the stars never became
more confrontational than that but their
lack of real life friendship has been
apparent in the years since the show was
ended speaking of Ariana Grande she and
jennette mccurdy used to be close
friends and co-stars while on the set of
Sam and cat and even though they played
best friends on the show these ladies
have their fair share of beef the show
collapse in 2014 after mccurdy realized
that ariana grande was being paid much
more than she was despite being a
co-lead however ariana took to Twitter
to defend herself saying quote Janette
and I agreed upfront that we would be
treated equally on the show it all
regards as we should be considering we
each work just as hard as the other on
this show grande wrote
the rumors circulating about our
contracts and our salaries not being
equal are absolutely ridiculous and
false mccurdy then tried renegotiating
her contract but the entire thing fell
apart when Nickelodeon cancelled the
series later Jeannette wrote a
blistering essay about toxic friendships
and many readers assumed that the essay
was aimed at Ariana we don't know how
they feel about each other now but it
seems like their friendship couldn't
handle the cancellation of the show
Serena and Blair weren't just two girls
with aggressively rich teenager names
they were best friends and shade during
frenemies
but their relationship veered much more
toward the front side than enemies as it
turns out the same did not apply to
Blake Lively and Leighton Meester who
kept their relationship strictly
professional they were friendly but they
were not friends like Serena and Blair
yet the second they'd be on set together
it's as if they were and while they
never fought are got into two heated
arguments they were never particularly
close however according to a New York
magazine expose lively and Meester would
avoid each other like the plague on set
sadly SNB aren't friends in real life
but luckily for fans that never had an
impact on their fierce on-air chemistry
if you were a fan of the hills you were
most likely shocked when the on-screen
besties Lauren Conrad and Heidi Montag
cut their friendship short and became
public enemies
the duo's feud began in 2007 when
website Perez Hilton com published an
article that Lauren and her then
boyfriend Jason Wahler had made a tape
after the report made headlines
Conrad immediately took to her website
to negate the whole thing she also
mentioned that one of her close friends
didn't even call or text her after the
news broke and it was soon revealed that
the friend was Montag who took it upon
herself to respond in her own Us Weekly
interview saying she didn't reach out
because she was in the hospital while
recovering from her nose and boob jobs
well she definitely has a valid excuse
she may not have had the best of both
worlds but Miley didn't have the best of
friendships with her on-screen best
friend on the set of Hannah Montana
there's no denying that Hannah Montana's
Miley and Lilly had the type of
friendship we all longed for
however Cyrus shed a little more light
on her friendship with Osmond in her
autobiography miles to go admitting that
things weren't always peachy she said
Emily and I tried to be friends we
really did but it always ended up in a
fight she wrote our characters got along
so well
why couldn't we act the same
life nevertheless in March 2020 the
actresses had the reunion fans have been
waiting years for on Cyrus's Instagram
live talk show bright minded live with
Miley the reunion was just enough to
prove to fans that the former co-stars
are still great friends we couldn't go
as far as to label Naya Rivera and Leah
Michels characters on Glee as close
however they did share special moments
that made fans view them as friends
instead of enemies but in real life nyan
Leia just couldn't stand each other
Naya believes it had something to do
with her role being expanded in her
autobiography sorry not sorry she
admitted their friendship broke down
throughout the series mostly because
Leia didn't like sharing the spotlight
she also said that her friendship with
Leia changed on the show to the point
where Leia stopped talking to her in the
final season we don't know if things are
better now but from the sound of things
Glee was just a dramatic behind the
camera as it wasn't front in the movie
they play members of the same stripping
troupe but the pair never warmed to each
other on set Pettyfer admitted they
didn't get on because Channing Tatum
does not like me and for many reasons
many being my own fault Magic Mike is
roughly based on Tatum's own stripping
career and he has producer an investor
in the project saw Pettifer as a big
risk later there seems to have been a
bit of business relating to unpaid rent
Pettyfer rented a flat from one of
Tatum's mates then moved out suddenly
and didn't pay rent
when Pettifer turned up for Magic Mike
reshoots the tide had turned against him
Channing had already told everyone he
didn't like me
he explains and what Channing says goes
because he's a movie star one can
imagine that Tatum decided it would be
easier not to bring Pettifer its
character back for the sequel it's no
secret Alexa Nicholas who played though
his best friend Nicole on zoey 101 and
Jamie Lynn didn't get along back in
there Zoe 101 days Alexa left the show
in 2006 after two seasons amid rumors
that she was feuding with Jamie Lynn the
actress was written off the show after
the second season due to constant
off-screen fights with the show star
Jamie Lynn Spears in 2019 news came out
that a zoey 101 reboot may be in the
works
followed by photos of nearly the whole
cast reuniting except for alexa nikolas
she expressed the hurt she felt about
not being invited to the reunion in a
series of emotional Instagram videos she
revealed that the potential reboot is
triggering childhood trauma since this
is a BFF list we can't forget to mention
the most famous BFFs on screen and in
life the pair were practically
inseparable in the early 2000s and were
rarely seen without the other close by
since they were so close it didn't come
as a surprise to fans when the
socialites eventually landed their very
own hit reality show The Simple Life the
series ran for three seasons and
featured the real-life BFFs getting into
all sorts of antics as they went from
being fairly Hill socialites to
performing blue-collar work in 2005 the
infamous friendship we once knew was no
more after hilton announced during Us
Weekly's young hot Hollywood style
Awards that Ritchie would no longer be a
part of their reality series Paris
quotes said it's my show I've had it for
three seasons and I just want to freshen
it up
Hilton confessed that she and Ritchie
weren't friends saying it's no big
secret that Nicole and I are no longer
friends Nicole knows what she did and
that's all I'm ever going to say about
it nina dobrev and Paul Wesley might
have appeared like the perfect friends
and lovers while on the set of Vampire
Diaries but these two didn't always get
along
thankfully they are confirmed besties
now but according to the probe though
on-screen lovers turned friends couldn't
stand each other for the first five
months of filming their show
I respected Paul Wesley I didn't like
Paul Wesley Nina Dobrev revealed on the
directionally challenged podcast in June
2019 she insisted they were best friends
and any kinks in their relationship was
just a part of becoming a family on set
we just didn't appreciate each other as
much as we do now it's a moment in time
that we'll never get back and I look
back at it so fondly it made us who we
are in the best way possible Preston
Burke and Derek Shepherd grew close
after surviving many life-threatening
situations on Grey's Anatomy in real
life however Patrick Dempsey and Isaiah
Washington were anything but it was
first reported that the two got into a
physical altercation while on the show
Isaiah got all in Patrick's face because
he was late for work going as far as to
grab him by the throat later
Washington was fired and ridden off the
show after allegedly using a homophobic
slur towards another co-star TR Knight
who played dr. George O'Malley
but even though Washington stated
multiple times that he wasn't homophobic
this effectively ended his time on the
show while Jack and Charlie got along
great on lost their real-life
counterparts decidedly did not which
came as a shock to many the drama began
when an earnest fan asked monoghan to
get his buddy and former co-star Fox on
the social networking app the actors
bonded with a terse he beats women
no thanks box wasn't gonna take a
beating without a fair fight he
responded in an interview with Men's
Journal in the 46 years I've been
breathing on this planet I have never
hit a woman before never have never will
bickering droids c-3po and r2d2 were
best buddies on-screen but it is
regrettably true that Kenny Baker and
Anthony Daniels didn't always get along
in the Star Wars movies Baker repeatedly
took jabs at Daniel's for years I just
don't like him and have never understood
what his problem is
four years after the prequel trilogy was
done they were both invited to appear at
a Star Wars event and Baker reportedly
said it depends if you invite his
lordship the one with the golden balls I
won't be there Milano into hearty played
not just best friends but sisters the
three Halliwell sisters on charms we're
as close as can be which is why fans
were devastated when two Hardy's
character Prue was killed off in season
3 rumor has it the two butted heads
while working on the early seasons of
Charmed without naming milano directly
to hardy claimed I don't want to work
with people who beat about their job and
complain about it and say they hate it
or anything else
given the rumoured tension on the set it
was only a matter of time before
somebody left the series and that
somebody was the Hardy who said goodbye
to the show in 2001 up through season 2
of The Good Wife Margules and punjabi's
characters were best friends until it
was revealed that punjabi's Kalinda had
slept with Margules character's husband
in the past after that the two appeared
much less frequently on-screen together
but according to vogue a long rumored
feud between the co-stars may have
played a role in the plot twist mark
Ulis confirmed that the season 6 finale
had been shot separately due to Punjabis
filming the fall at the same time
however Punjabi wasn't having it she
fired back saying the fall was not even
in production at that time and I was in
New York ready to film the scene um we
smell animosity yes I'm sorry
it's surprising to know that your
favorite on-screen besties weren't so
friendly but there's no denying that
these actors have done an amazing job
hiding their fuse which of these
frenemies surprised you the most let us
know in the comments below and don't
forget to Like and subscribe thanks for
watching the things bye for now